hello guys Greg Alva here this is Evan
Dollard having the dollar and an D
honored alright we're gonna do today cuz
holidays are coming up and I know people
like to watch a funny film around the
holidays we're gonna do our top 5
favorite comedies these might not be
your favorite comedies I get it I get it
and sometimes my list changes right now
I have this 5 through 1 list but you
know sometimes what's number 5 might be
number 1 depending on my feelings this
is working on the week and depending on
the mood like my this list fluctuates
for me so basically loads of good
companies out there just it depends what
kind of mood you're in right stupid
comedy is an action comedy and comedy is
very much subjective it is like all kind
of genres out the comedy is especially
subjective so I'll kick this off my
number 5 is dumb and dumber
in terms of stupid comedies this is one
of the more clever ones to me I think
it's one of those clever dumb comedies I
like it when they can do something where
people are very stupid but there's
something kind of witty about the way
it's being executed and I really just
think like a lot of the bits are so
[ __ ] memorable you know mock yeah
because the suits that they wear Jim
Carrey was hilarious in it the stupid
comedy is not my favorite yeah type of
comedy I like I like a shtick that was a
little too stupid stream however to your
point very memorable it's a classic and
there's something to be said about
something that can influence culturally
have such an influence that it does it's
like a gross out of humor that I was
like it surprisingly doesn't cross the
line into r-rated territory well there's
some pretty gross gags in there very
true when he has like diarrhea I just
think I thought Jim Carrey was [ __ ]
hysterical in that and growing up in the
90s I felt like Jim Carrey was truly the
comedian in my era anyway who's your
who's your number 5 number 5 I have
love you man I am yeah my list coming up
soon oh it's boiler alert boiler yeah I
love it please tell me what yeah I love
Paul Rudd he's a great everyman where
he's not classically handsome but he's
conventionally you know attractive but
he's just funny and I believe the
relationship between him and rashida
Jones and I like the idea of a guy
that's so invested in love that he
neglects have a male relationships yeah
so someone trying to navigate a
relationship with a very dear stock man
like Jason Segel was there open to
talking about everything he's a master
fiction station got the man cave and he
essentially teaches Paul Rudd how to be
friends with other guys and it was very
refreshing for me to watch that it made
me laugh out loud a lot I thought that
was a movie had a great balance of
heightened reality mixed with just
reality yeah I felt I could never cross
too far into ridiculous territory
sometimes you got a little ridiculous
like a Lou Ferrigno and all that [ __ ]
but right but other than that it was it
still stayed pretty grounded you know
yeah well voice guy yeah it was mainly
the chemistry between Jason Segel and
Paul Rudd that I just really loved
there's a lot of bromance films that
have been coming out of the past like
decade or so I'm not gonna lie I teared
up at the end scene my number four is
knocked up knocked up surprisingly when
I saw knocked up the first time I didn't
like it I thought it was annoying it's
[ __ ] the first time I saw it but I
realized I was like into this chick at
the time and she was like saying nice to
this guy didn't like and they were
laughing so she was distracted by that
so I saw it years later I really enjoyed
um I've been through heavy stoner
periods in my life and I enjoyed that
comedy because it was so vulgar and it
was so raunchy but it had this
incredible blend of magical heart like
you see this guy go on this journey of
lazy unproductive stoner running a like
nude side to being a dedicated like I'm
gonna commit to this by the end being
like a loyal father and you really see
him grow and I like seeing the
mismatched personalities like really
like it felt very fluid it felt very
natural
and it's hysterical it's a heart it's
moving I really enjoyed that film and I
thought the whole supporting cast was
great 240 cast is incredible it was cool
to see as you said the growth of the
character yeah you're looking at Dumb
and Dumber you can see again it's
there's this guy who he's he's stuck in
this way and nothing turns you right
like I'm faster I imagined yeah being
responsible for a child and he steps up
to the challenge yeah it's great because
he doesn't like abandon his friends but
he done you see by the end of the film
that he does decide to keep a distance
from them because he knows he can't live
that lifestyle anymore right I like that
balance of not I can't be friends with
you anymore but I just got to keep you
know some space yeah I thought I thought
it was very well done and I still think
it honored all the raunchiness with
still keeping it like it's like a weird
raunchy family yeah so what's your
number for mr. Evan Dollard number for
neighbors oh my gosh
Zac Efron kills me in the hilarious I
feel like I'm talking a lot about
attractiveness which I don't mean to do
but like you can't deny that he's an
attractive man yes
and when someone who when someone who's
that attractive that can play drama he
can play really those there was
conventional leading man roles yes and
he just plays this hilarious frat guy
that has no idea which way is up yeah
and like gets into this insane conflict
with the next-door neighbors and Rose
Byrne I loved her so much - I really
like Seth Rogen like what should be
adults getting into this dispute with a
fraternity it's ridiculous absolutely
ridiculous I thought it was hilarious I
thought it was hilarious going with Zac
Efron that that was the film that I
think earned him a lot more respect from
everyone because before then he was kind
of just a pretty boy yeah I've seen High
School Musical and then he was doing
like these dramas that people were like
Zac Efron when he did neighbors people
thought he was so [ __ ] funny that and
one a lot of people over with Zac Efron
has a hole Zac Efron was great in that
and I even like the whole cast and I
think Dave Franco's funny in it right at
us the one guy who played Sarah
his best friend he's actually one of the
one of the writers of Central
Intelligence is he really yeah oh I know
which after you're talking about I can
think of his name right now yeah he's
guy says the n-word on a lot of really
great memorable bits in that film and I
like the way that film ended - yeah like
with how they may dress I feel like Seth
Rogen knows how to make films with heart
yeah like you don't see the heart coming
that's what I love about them you think
you're just in for another raunchy
vulgar time but then they're always
manages to be a great heart at the end
of it comedies with heart by far my
favorite which you'll see as we get
deeper is a list my number three is
another Judd Apatow film it's a Will
Ferrell film anchorman the legend or
Romberg yes that film just because of
how old I wasn't that came out I
remember I spent like a whole summer I
saw that film maybe like nineteen times
it's to the point now where I just can't
watch it anymore
can i watch it I just know every line
yeah but it's still one of my favorites
because it's so unbelievably quotable
you know that was like before Paul Rudd
became like really big the force that
was when Steve Carell was like who the
hell's do you correctly yeah
and that's what God will Farrow really
on the mat so that film was very
legendary and it's cool because you know
jet happens how produced it but it
doesn't feel like a Judd Apatow film
he's just the producer it still feels
like an adamant K wolf Ferrell film yes
and I thought it was very tightly
constructed I thought was great spoof of
the 70s I felt like a lot of its humor
was trying to be replicated way after
that and I don't think any of Will
Ferrell's comedies quite lived up to
that elbow there is films like the other
guys which is great Talladega Nights oh
wait a minute
let's Oh continue this list in command
was more or less honorable mention in
this list because when I watched it
first watched it it was the hardest I
think I'd left ya watching in the comedy
ever up to that point the character of
Ron Burgundy is so fun
you see bits of it in different
characters since then yeah there's so
much Ron Burgundy I feel like yeah under
the surface of the character in blades
of glory gosh yeah anchorman was a
honorable mention in for mine and I
loved about him
- is that like it's it's called
anchorman legend Ron Burgundy and you
got a great cast in there
everyone's so hysterical Paul Rudd has
his memorable you know 60% of the time
it works every time and Steve Carell had
like just to stand out lines and ever
just so ridiculous but it's still
managed to make Ron Burgundy the
funniest one you know yeah that's now it
was cool it's like everyone shine in EM
everyone except chant but everyone else
really I thought really shine and Steve
Carell it was a real I feel like that
was a real milestone in his career
because he had been my understanding
comedic actor based out of Chicago doing
sketch and improv and maybe second city
and then I remember watching what was it
Bruce Almighty yeah he wasn't daily show
then Bruce Almighty yeah and then
anchorman here's became known as like
the news guy yeah remember that scene in
Bruce Almighty like obviously Jim
Carrey's hysterical he can't take it
away from him but he's kind of behind
the scenes making Steve Carell talk a
certain like talk ridiculousness and I
remember thinking that actor is
phenomena who is that guy
and just fall in love Steve Carell
somebody got it finally got that that
role an anchorman I don't feel like
Steve Carell has done stupid comedy as
well as he did an anchorman he's in
command - yeah as much as I wanted to
love it I just couldn't did you ever see
it
anchorman - yeah I mean I tried really
liking it just felt a little forced yeah
I feel like Steve Carell was perfect
after how many years 15 years or
whatever it had a lot to live up to
anyway number three the other guys other
guys I'm hilarious but I love a good
action comedy this one every time Mark
Wahlberg just rails Ferrell the pairing
is perfect between the two of them Will
Ferrell so uptight he loves his
spreadsheets he loves sit in the office
and Mark Wahlberg needs to get out there
and get [ __ ] done one of my favorite
movies from that or favorite scenes from
that movie well first you meet his wife
for the first time yes he was Eva Mendes
yeah smokin hot yeah Mark Wahlberg
doesn't know what's going on like asking
no really who is this woman later in the
film they meet up with one of
Farrell's exes and she's like crazy but
still in love with them trying to hit on
him and like moving his mouth like I
love you Kristina like just insane
there's a good spoof film yeah because
it but it's more than just a spoof of
cop films you know it's called the other
guy sets foot and I love Mark Wahlberg's
character of this cop who wants to be a
badass cop like he just thinks he's a
badass cop and he's doing like whenever
something bad happens like it's the
Colombians what do you say that it's
nothing cool um you see he did something
bigger
my father chemistry was amazing does he
ever like opening dancer when he's like
if I was a lion I'd swim out into the
ocean quickly that isn't Adam McKay film
correct that's Adamek a fun Apatow film
produced but it is Adam again after
watching the Big Short and then looking
back at the other guys yeah oh you can
see part of the other guys was it wraps
up with that company was too big to fail
yeah and you see him trying to weave
into these these political or social
political and economical themes and
mikay it's the big short you see I think
what he's ultimately that's been going
on in his brain the whole time yeah
knows how to write stupid comedy kind of
inserts different themes of seriousness
that pertain to the economy and
politically or big short it's just like
oh this is how you comedy while
addressing the most serious yeah
economic issue of our time great
character you got it and McKay's not
just a very funny man he's a genius my
number two is another 90s comedy oh this
film consistently makes me cry at the
end wire life oh yes
I don't know how everyone feels about
Lyle are due this day but to me that's
one of my favorite Jim Carrey
performance it's like I feel like when
you watch like the great Jim Carrey
films like the masks
Ace Ventura Dumb and Dumber liar liar
people tend to huge Jim Carrey I've
always playing the same guy but when you
watch them you're like you know what
there are differences between each
character when I see liar liar that was
that one of those roles where I was like
only Jim Carrey could have pulled this
off there's no other actor that could
have brought that ridiculousness and
heart to a character
that well is a fun parody of like being
a lawyer and I thought one of those
great like 90s you know like solid
logline plots a lawyer who can't lie
yeah definitely hi Connor hi Gary
yeah those moments in that film just
they I think it's very touching and I
love his growth as a human being by the
end and it's kind of corny at times but
I felt like it's it's it works you know
like I saw that movie when I was really
young there was a lot of kids in the
theater when I saw it and I'm like
there's a lot of adult jokes in that
film it does feel like a family film
it's still about a father and son like
yeah the films still about a father and
his little kid I think that's a very
touching film and when he tells his kid
how much he loves him at the end how
ridiculous he's going just to tell him
how much he loves his son on the plane I
just makes me cry oh I just that just
gets to my heart father-son stuff you
got a you got a soft you got a soft soft
spot there I'm more than just muscles
number two well now we're getting into
the more I guess heartfelt are more
serious comedies ish ish 500 days of
summer I liked that it was one it made
me laugh consistently the first
especially the first time I saw it and
how it was billed as not a love story
yeah this is not a love story and they
lived up to it and the idea of
expectation versus reality and seeing
this relationship all the reasons why
you feel like it should work and then it
doesn't and even the way that it was cut
together we were going back and forth in
time yeah like the number of days during
the relationship and ultimately the
recovery since then I know I think any
guy that's been that's had their heart
broken
can watch that film and be like yes
you'd like your love and hate are so
close to each other Oh totally and one
of my favorite moments are one of the
defining moments in that film for me was
when they went back showed all the same
clips of what he loved about her and
then contrasted it with by saying now I
hate all these things like a hater
stupid birthmark yeah or a hater
whatever it is it just rings so true
it's kind of a hard film to watch
oh yeah it's a weird kind of like funny
movie that's also like I think it's
especially if you're going through a
breakup it's like it's a hard film oh
yeah you're going through a breakup
don't
because what did you want to relate to
the film you're like this is like too
much man I know where that I really know
what's going on here the performances
are great I mean I really like Zooey
Deschanel like really boom from that
film and Joseph gordon-levitt I felt
really started getting I mean he was
already on the rise yeah I really feel
like that was like a great two powerful
performances in one and it was it was
like that romantic comedy that's not a
romantic comedy I thought that was very
well done cuz like I know like the
break-up try being that you know like oh
yeah but this film I felt successfully
achieved that where it was like it's
still heartfelt you still love it but it
also breaks your heart at the same time
you know yeah so yeah good choice Evan
oh thank you my number one is Evans
number five um I Love You Man another
one that's my number one yeah I mean I
love the movie hey it's subjective I
Love You Man like right now for me I
feel like we're in this day and age
where guys are being a lot more
vulnerable you know guys I feel like
less more much like macho and like
they're willing to put their guard down
more and be honest and stuff and relate
more I feel like I see a lot of guys who
are like are willing to go to therapy
and all that stuff
so when I see I Love You Man that's a
movie with like two dudes who are just
putting down their walls just really
like they like love each other and their
Bonnie in it and it shows the importance
of friendship and I love that rashida
Jones was someone who was very
supportive you know like there's a time
where she was being unsupportive but but
for the most part for the most of the
film she's very supportive of like you
need to have a guy friend how important
that is most importantly I related it at
film when there's room for came out I
remember I had like one guy friend who I
was very close to him but I all my other
friends were girls and I had a
girlfriend at that time so I understood
that feeling of like I don't really know
what it's like to be a dude sometimes I
just feel like I feel like I'm a more of
an open honest sensitive guy so I feel
like a lot of my friends were females
but to have guy friends I feel like is a
totally different dynamic then when you
have a female friend and I think it's
essential for guys to have guy friends
yeah yeah I mean you're touching on the
the themes of masculinity which always
is to me important and worth while
discussing because there's so many
stereotypes isn't the right word but
perspectives or I want to say here
you're saying a lot of synonyms of like
cliche cliche yeah okay but there lived
out is part of the problem so if you've
ever been to your video UFC fight it's
all [ __ ] it really is and then you
have biker gangs like you see all these
videos on YouTube where oh you you're
like fronting and while I've got all my
guys and we ride bikes and we're gonna
beat your ass you feel like we need to
be a certain way yeah at the same time
if you're overly sensitive then you're
not yeah so where do you find that
balance and I appreciate a movie that
can discuss it with Yammer yeah exactly
you leave watching the movie or leaving
the theater thinking about it it's a
weird film cuz you're like I love my
best friend yeah it's done cuz you know
that moment where they when they finally
say I love you to each other like guys
don't like girls
I feel like Sam all the time I notice
girls can be like I love you I love you
too guys have to say like I love you bro
I love you man I love how they parodied
that yeah you know like all the other
funny things they were saying I love you
Jovi and stuff yeah yeah I felt that was
a really cool I thought that was a
really cool kind of unique comedy and I
think Paul Rudd is just amazing in it
yes that's his most different role to me
if you like watch any of these usually
just sarcastic [ __ ] he's like
sarcastic ass level the heart yeah and
this film he's not that he's not but
he's hilarious in the film he's
sensitive he's endearing hey Mike and
Jason Segel is like the I don't know I
thought was a cool perspective on dudes
and it makes me appreciate my guy
friends yeah love you Evan Oh
love you bro number one Crazy Stupid
Love hey stupid racist Erica film love
that movie two pieces from Josh Groban's
cameo to Steve Carell getting shit-faced
Ryan Gosling approaching him in the bar
and taking mine under his wing Ryan
Gosling being the one that falls in love
with Steve Carell water
if the movie is flawless as far as I'm
concerned but it starts in such a dark
note which is Steve Carell's wife
cheating on it and it's like how do you
take such a difficult premise to deal
with in general like that's hard to
watch yeah and then they turned it into
like a very funny moving moment with
plenty of those bromance moments between
asti throne Ryan Gosling yeah Ryan
Gosling Wallace so funny if he I mean I
love Steve Kerr on that but I never
everyone really thinking about Ryan
Gosling because he's done like some
comedies like I know that Lars and the
real girl is like a funny performance
but this was a different kind of you
mean again role it was a weird one yeah
this is a different kind of comedic role
and he was great in it but I loved that
movie I remember when that movie was
done that was final moments where you
just see Julianne Moore and Steve Carell
laughing and talking with each other and
having that hope for them there was
something that was magical about that
like I felt really good it doesn't end
on a note of like they're definitely
getting together but it ends on a note
of like hope I felt very good about it
like a respect and understanding and you
could see that they at least still loved
each other in a certain way
yeah I'm Ryan Gosling and Emma Stone's
Emma Stone's role comes in late into the
film man how magical was her chemistry
how's magic like any lala lands coming
out watch that film best movie I've seen
all year go it in a song yeah Simon
Zurich and that was an amazing amazing
amazing film like that's if you thought
their chemistry was like great and Crazy
Stupid Love just wait till you watch
this for highs so yeah and say hey let's
find crazy below is like the origin of
the Emma Stone Ryan Gosling pairing you
know good choice oh you good choices you
good choices all right rejects what are
your favorite comedies is that a fun
youtube question I bet nobody's asked
you no one on YouTube ever with their
favorite comedy movies we're doing a
comedy video near the channel subscribe
today become a reject Evan Dollard is on
the social medias of all the social
medias myspace Napster is my two big
ones humble
still actively promoting hi Zanna
Instagram YouTube and Derby links in the
description box go there find him and
enjoy your holiday season plenty to be
thankful for hmm I need like Bros Bros I
know what I'm thankful for
Oh